thank us north of the wall I have to go
north I have to hey youtubers it's
Charlie happy day after Halloween since
so many of us are suffering from bad
candy hangovers and a lot of you have
been requesting I do a video for brand
for a game of thrones season 4 here it
is congratulations one of the reasons
why brain is so important in the story
of a song of ice and fire and on the
show Game of Thrones is because he
really shows us how sometimes a lot of
the weakest characters can end up
becoming the most powerful characters
that's part of brands journey and a song
of ice and fire you can think of him as
being like a very mystical tyrion and
although we don't really know how these
characters stories are going to end just
because the last two books haven't even
been written yet we do know that their
characters are on this path to greatness
so if you're finding me for the first
time or you haven't seen any of my game
of thrones season 4 videos yet consider
this a mild spoiler warning for brand in
book 5 that's right they're really
accelerating his story from book 5 to
the show because technically we're still
in the second half of book 3 where most
of the show takes place in season 4
that's just because brands character
does not have a lot of scenes on the
show and that's going to continue in
season for the during season three brand
learned all about this special power he
had called warning giving him the
ability to skin change into the bodies
of other animals odor learned the hard
way that you can even control people too
but like that scene applies brands power
is much more powerful than any of the
other people in the show that can warg
he has this really deep connection with
something called the three-eyed Raven
and that's basically what Jojen is
trying to help him learn more about that
actually has ties to something called
the green seer technically the
three-eyed Raven is almost like the
avatar of the green seer you can think
of him as like this Jedi Master that
lives north of the wall that has this
magical ability that we haven't really
learned about on the show yet so at the
end of season 3 they basically had just
made it to the wall so that are getting
ready to travel north of the wall to
find this greenseer somewhere in the
frozen north there's a few things about
brands journey that might change from
the books to the show is because they
haven't officially cast the character
named cold hands that's actually a
really interesting character I won't
talk about him too much in this video
because it's not guaranteed that he's
going to be on the show but we
definitely know that the green seer the
three-eyed Raven that is is on the show
the interesting thing that really sets
brand apart from the younger characters
on the show is that his character just
totally buys in to the fact
that he has this mystical ability he
just totally accepts it and goes along
for the ride so he's basically on the
path to becoming a Jedi in the world of
Game of Thrones he just hasn't quite
found the Jedi Master yet but more to
that store was referenced the green seer
or the three-eyed Raven as the show is
probably going to call him is actually a
lot like Yoda he basically is in this
really Zen state in this area in the
frozen north just kind of waiting for
Brando arrived he's basically trying to
guide brand to him in this really subtle
way using nature and animals I don't
want to talk too much about what green
seeing powers actually encompass but
it's basically power over nature in this
really profound way but it's actually
really cool and I'll be really
interested to see how the show treats it
from a visual standpoint the actual
character the greens here is really
really interesting it has this really
amazing history so i'll be doing a
separate video just for him be sure to
subscribe to get it he's actually named
the Bloodraven and used to be this
bastard of one of the Targaryen kings
who actually started the Blackfyre
rebellion so i'll be talking about all
that in that video but brand story in
season four is mostly going to be him
travelling to see the green see her just
because he's not gonna be in every
episode it's was not gonna have that
many scenes just like in season three we
probably won't meet that greenseer until
we get towards the end of the season but
once we get into season five and beyond
that's probably where we're going to see
more of brand in the middle of his Jedi
training that's actually going to be
really really exciting because I think
he's going to be really critical to the
fight against the great other and the
White Walkers even if he actually never
literally interacts with jon snow or
Stannis or any of the other characters
on the show that's one of the things I
really like about Game of Thrones is
that characters actually have very big
influence over each other even if they
never see each other if you can't tell
by the fact that I dedicated a whole
video to him I'm super excited to see
Brandon season for one reason is that he
is a big tie to magic on the show like
Melisandre we don't have a lot of
magical people on the show magic is
still pretty rare it definitely exists
so brand is going to teach us about a
slightly different kind of magic that
Melisandre has that there's anything
that I didn't talk about in the video
that you have big questions about for a
brand story be sure to write them in the
comments and we'll discuss why we
actually know quite a bit about season 4
at this point so I'm really excited also
be sure to leave me your request for my
next game of Thrones video a lot of you
have been requesting Margaery Tyrell so
I might do her next but there's still a
lot more important characters that I
haven't done yet I'll be
boosting my next legend decor video at
eight-thirty p.m. pacific time tonight
be sure to subscribe to get it in the
meantime you can click here to browse
all of my game of thrones season 4
videos I have a bunch of them now so be
sure to check I'm probably have done
your favorite character already but if I
haven't be sure to let me know and I
will add it to my list you can also
click here to catch up on legend of
korra for tonight thank you so much for
watching high five see you guys tonight